this world is beyond cruelty
you've been fighting the Hurricanes for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
your father didn't believe in Revenge we
from it let me fight beside you
oh
reload
[Music]
he said I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him I'm fighting
for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it because of all my Visions lead to
horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the trades is still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
your father
was a weak man
who's back from the dead
No Deal must be done
we gave them something to hope for
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
tradies
Duke Uncle Ruckus
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]